hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to Octodad now you
really thought that that did me and it
takes more than that to remove
markiplier sanity from his brain machine
thing whole head in fiddling it takes
more than that to remove markiplier
sanity and I'm back with a vengeance I
actually gave my voice a day to rest but
as you can see it's somber tones are
back and better than ever so I'm gonna
go up there and talk to my lady and then
bang her right in front of the sharks
and make another baby hey baby let's
bang with unprotected tuck the guitars
you understood what I meant there
unprotected tentacles did you know that
octopi reproduce by filling one of their
tentacles with octopus sperm and then
ripping it off and shoving it into the
reproductive organ of the female octopus
wasn't that just a delightful statement
that everyone is so glad that they know
that now I bet there's a tie-in ones
heck no no yep oh no could you let go of
that one please I said let go oh you
you're not gonna get me it's in
this one no nevermind then was all a lie
hey baby you like you're perfectly
normal hundred oh no oh my oh no awaken
this time oh oh I look so weird naked
what are you I just want to live a happy
life
not everybody face not everyone's fish
it doesn't matter Oh back where you
belong
oh no this bad I'm in the shark tank oh
it looks so weird
don't get it no your family the bad new
why is it so disturbing for me
did I really think that I was human oh
this feels so wrong oh it feels so weird
what is going on why is that the
weirdest thing to me he's been walking
around pretending to be human banging
his human wife and what oh my god oh I'm
still control where's the captain you
know him probably taking a shower
uh-huh in the middle of a rainstorm
right so I need to get over here
undetected so I need to go around
oh he's watching right there oh my how
am I gonna do this while he's watching
over there
oh they're turning Vinu uh-huh what are
you doing man how about a little bit of
collaboration okay
some of you said that the last
one was gonna be the hardest level and I
don't need to worry about it anymore
no no no this ain't good okay got it
yeah got it all right baby I'm back with
a vengeance what if I killed him with
what this hook over here Hey look over
there
isn't that disturbing god damn okay yeah
somebody lied to me someone lied to me a
lot someone's seriously messed up here
okay let's just guys not turning what
kind of douche bag is he no no no no no
no no no I'm good everybody would you do
buddhu perfectly normal perfectly normal
early normal Oh normal normal normal
normal normal normal my other leg news
normal Armel normal normal okay that was
easy
I'm just gonna rest here for a bit while
my detecto meter goes down you guys
didn't see anything no blur
where am I we're not I kill oh there I
am oza for whatever let go of the
staircase and get under to get on round
the stairs the other side you're gonna
let go that you're gonna disappear
completely I know you have camouflage
but I didn't know is that good can you
let go what is it oh my god - why does
he keep there we go okay so apparently
my dick tech domitor isn't going to go
away so where do I go to get inside I'm
gonna go around this again oh no oh no I
oh no no no wooden oh no no okay
apparently I got to go up this way
come on come on done this a million
times now there's a million times
million times million times million
times million times oh so many times
that we have done this and not done it
this way what you lost your student you
lost all coordination and balance you
can't even get it even room oh come on
what is your print election for not
going there what is your major
malfunction octopi could you put a thank
you god damn Wow am I supposed to get in
there that's not gonna work
can I get up there I get up there come
on just a little higher man a little
higher little higher a little higher a
little higher come on
little higher little higher high hi-ho
hi-ho it's off to work we go hope you
guys are enjoying the show where I'm
going I'm not supposed to know I hope it
doesn't start to snow boy yeah sure I'm
going slow if I put a maybe I put a leg
on this handrail okay all right and
raise this up up up up up up up now okay
Ferenc I can't even place it up there
well I'm just gonna rest my crotch up
here and look sassy for a bit Oh
that's right and it good I look damn
good
who's swimmy oh yeah okay so I'm a
little confused
it was an artifice oh come on I thought
I was being stealthy what I'm all the
way back here oh this would have been
much more intelligent to do oh that's
genius
now if only I could oh my oh no oh no
it's not as genius as I thought it might
be oh this is not as genius
oh goodness gravy I feel like I've had
27,000 drinks after all God it got
thinner why did it get thinner
hey why is that you see any sales uh oh
thank you oh yeah that's a much better
name logic aha I am great thank you for
noticing mine oh god no no balls balls
balls balls barrels balls barrels balls
barrels can you open it
thank you please let go now go in hey
rosemary small barrels I'm taking this
with me good
Oh notice the thing can I change into a
sailor's outfit Oh No okay
Yeow Oh God is filled with bananas why
would it be filled with bananas Goerke
straddling you're slipping straddling
slipping straddling slipping straddling
opening suit suit yeah thank you yes
all right away I'm going don't mind me
we're Weasley nermal pervy Leonardo all
right yes
yes Marilla no no normal thank you thank
you for cooperating with me I'm just
gonna be on my way sorry I had a few
drinks
oh yeah exactly
excuse me pardon me just ice skating for
a bit gimme to normal what don't take
any chances sailor the rough storm out
here we can all die tonight maybe not me
but you definitely you you're gonna die
tonight you and your taut chest in your
lovely what you look good sailor smack
good job let's go just skating my way
downtown walking round ain't no pound in
the hound down no don't mind me okay yep
got it nailed it this time boy am i good
huh I got my sea legs back on me and I'm
ready to go
all hail the captain goodness start the
boat caliber all hail me the other
captain is mysteriously been killed in
Aidid taking the helm with my leg in
place oh yes of course
all right what do we need to do I need
to start this bad boy up sugar sugar
sugar sugar
you're good risking to Kentucky town I
asked Tim for second do you doing maybe
we're moving again free yes what site
pulling beard of clown you're welcome
yes ever flowing beard of whatever
lalalala did I see my lovely wife down
there
lalala la chica hot you know look out
rough seas ahead oh my did I do that who
is that woman
indeed who is that woman I must discover
get out of my way the captain is moving
box Oh God just me or the room can seem
geekier than evil no of course not
I'm just kidding oh god damn it no no no
it no excuse me lady yes sorry for
stowing away please don't throw me
overboard maybe I should
well now we're both in trouble who are
you then Hey look what ha ha
aren't we a pair ha ha ha ha
I've got to knock oh my what what do you
mean what is what does that mean how am
I supposed to sneak past him
what do you mean sneak past him ok here
we go
going going going going for it oh yeah
ok
I'm gonna wait fully turns again and go
now no no no no right over here
oh come on why would you turn around
yeah that's right what for you stop
before you kick me off can I ask you
some questions about the war yep yep yep
yep yep yep yep
you have your absence ah yup yup you
have some strong opinions
ah Oh get out of the way box of card tie
please move my other leg that would be
natural captain on deck
all hail nice ass there ooh nice face -
how about you the other toss botoxing
smack good job show okay and here we go
any minute now
right now y'all hush hope you die good
job I let him knock my wife okay good
you always find you okay good job aren't
you sweet I hope that man is okay no I
don't ha ha remember alright alright so
what about you mystery man who are you
but cool I'm just here someday
in the meantime
would you care for a dance
look at this big bag yeah yeah go away
from the boat totally smart to do okay
you know what it's not the most
ridiculous thing to happen so whatever
perfectly fine by me
oh it's a heartwarming story love it
effective okay
I'm better now oh look at me Oh
naturally
but once again isn't this a shark tank
and I might be a little bit concerned
I'm not moving either I'm just not doing
anything am i stuck I can't move oh it's
different controls okay anyway what
that's all the time that I ever this
part sorry everyone
but thank you all so much for watching
click the annotation for more videos and
I've done and as always we'll see you in
the next video bye
fishy fishy fishy